despite their vast differences in style
and tone throughout the decades every
Batman movie tends to pull from the same
handful of references and plot points
again and again to the point where you
can pretty much set your bat watch by
them hey did you know Bruce Wayne's
parents were shot by a mugger in front
of him when he was a kid if you didn't
it's safe to assume that you've never
seen a movie about The Dark Knight
because it comes up a lot
seriously we've had more scenes of
Thomas and Martha Wayne being gunned
down in an alley over the years than
we've had Batmobiles admittedly that
makes a lot of sense along with the bats
that inspired Bruce to put on a costume
in order to strike fear into the
superstitious cowardly lot that is
Gotham City's criminal underworld it's
the single most important thing about
his origin story still once you've seen
it happen for the fifth or sixth time it
starts to lose its impact even if each
version tries to add something new Tim
Burton's 1989 Batman film makes it a
major plot point by casting the murderer
as the crook who would eventually become
the Joker Batman Forever shows the
murderers multiple times as part of a
story where the Riddler is stealing
memories Batman Begins replaces the
traditional movie theatre with an opera
house and even shows us the trial of a
remorseful Joe Chill something that's
never really been done in another Batman
story Donna
not a day goes by that I don't wish I
could take back what he did Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice leans into slow
motion close-ups and puts a spin on it
by having bats burst out of Martha
Wayne's tomb the one Batman film that
doesn't feature the Wayne's murders is
of course Batman the movie which ties
into the 1966 Adam West TV series and
back to in the show's entire 120 episode
run Plus the movie the killing is only
ever mentioned once in highlights
perhaps if there'd been anti-crime
centers of the type you now propose when
my own parents were murdered by
dastardly criminals it seems like Warner
Brothers finally made up for that in
2018 when they included what might just
be the darkest and most hilarious take
on the Wayne murders and the
kid-friendly Teen Titans go to the
movies
who knew Robin was that stone-cold more
than any other superhero Batman has an
incredible roster of compelling villains
with a deep bench that goes from
worldwide threats like Raza rule to
sinister nuisances like the Riddler and
even classic anti heroes like Catwoman
who had become main characters worthy of
a spotlight in their own right there are
the best bad guys in comics as a result
the Batman movies are always eager to
introduce a new villain and almost all
of them make sure to dive into their
origin stories Jack is dead my friend
you can call me Joker the big exception
is of course Batman 66 we're all four
baddies are already well-known arts
criminals just like they are on the show
the rest of them however go hard at
origins Batman 89 doesn't just show us
the Joker going into a vat of acid it
gives us his complete backstory is the
underling of a mob boss complete with
its own web of double-cross it's you my
number one guy Batman Returns does even
more not only do we see Selina Kyle's
breakdown Andrea merchants as Catwoman
we also get the Penguins literal life
story from infancy to death Batman
Begins shows us the Scarecrow's
transition from weirdo doctor to pull-on
supervillain and Batman and Robin that
movie actually does this four times
giving us the origin of poison ivy a
backstory for mr. freeze that explains
why he looks like a bodybuilder a
beginning for Bane and if you want to
get technical about it it even has an
origin story per Jason woods room the
floor on ik man it's easy to point to
the Dark Knight as a movie that
studiously avoids giving its major
villain a backstory as the Joker gives a
few conflicting versions of his past to
preserve his mystery instead it's a film
focused on the origin of super villainy
itself in addition to giving us a full
origin for two-face
it also shows the Joker's first reign of
terror in Gotham City which ends up
being the end of traditional organized
crime and a beginning for costumed super
criminals for decades Alfred Pennyworth
was Batman's loyal and somewhat bumbling
butler with a few notable exceptions
however the movies tend to avoid
introducing Robin and Albert became one
of the only people that Batman can speak
to casually as a result he became a
sarcastic comedic foil for the very
serious Dark Knight the clearest example
of this is probably Michael Caine's
betrayal of Albert in the Dark Knight
trilogy who seems to delight and
throwing shade at Batman and pretty much
everyone else did you get mold but I got
a dog it was a big dog it's definitely
present across all versions though the
Jeremy Irons version from Batman vs
Superman is the only counterbalance to
the movies otherwise all-consuming grim
Michael Gough salfred revels and dunking
on the Cape Crusader by telling
embarrassing childhood stories about
Bruce Wayne to his potential girlfriend
come on man let the guy have a couple of
secrets Batman's identity is one of his
most important secrets Bruce Wayne is
after all a very public figure whose
home address is pretty easy to figure
out so if his enemies ever discovered
exactly who was underneath that mask
he'd be in a whole lot of trouble and
there's also the fact that being a
vigilante is technically extremely
illegal no matter how many custom-made
spotlights you mount on top of the
police station and yet every time Batman
hits the silver screen the whole secret
part of his identity goes right out the
window the Dark Knight trilogy might
actually be the most egregious in this
regard
Ra's al Ghul knew from the very
beginning Rachel Dawes figures that out
thanks to Batman repeating a familiar
phrase and even some random dude who
works at Wayne Enterprises notices that
Batman's exclusively using stuff that
should be down in the warehouse and
Batman 89 Alfred just walks Vicki Vale
down to the Batcave one afternoon which
not only blows his secret identity
but also forces her to see the
unforgettable sights of batman wearing
mom jeans and Batman Forever the Riddler
learns it by literally stealing Bruce
Wayne's memories and then using the
information to blow up the Batcave
Justice League even features the scene
where the extremely famous Bruce Wayne
is just hanging out in public with
Aquaman talking about being Batman all
of that can be forgiven though because
it also gives us the single greatest
moment of Batman Returns and one of the
best scenes in any Batman movie when
Batman pulls off his mask to make a
heartfelt plea to Catwoman Max Schreck
played by Christopher Walken reacts the
way most of us would in that moment
while you dressed up like Batman because
he is
menu more check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite comic book
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]